[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a japanese time travel film
called samurai sensei spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
takeshi han pita is a samurai of the
tosa domain in the 18th century he is
considered a great warrior and is
respected by many however one day he is
accused of a crime and thrown in jail it
is yet to be revealed what his crime is
but he is scheduled to be executed one
morning takeshi wakes up and is not in
jail anymore he is shocked because he
clearly remembers going to sleep last
night on looking around he realizes he's
in an entirely unfamiliar place that
consists of people in strange clothing
and massive buildings it turns out he
has somehow time traveled 150 years into
the future he doesn't comprehend this
and thinks he has been transported into
a different city the passers-by look at
him strangely and assume he is
cosplaying as a samurai while wandering
around the foreign place he is almost
hit by a speeding bus it surprises him
to the core because he has never seen
something so fast somewhere nearby high
schooler torah is showing off his new
motorbike to his girlfriend haruka they
are approached by takechi who asks them
for directions to his village torah in
turn asks him about his cosplay which
offends to catchy haruka on the other
hand starts filming him amazed that he
looks like a real samurai after the
interaction takeshi walks into a grocery
store and picks up an apple he tells the
manager that he doesn't have any money
but promises to pay later the manager is
so stunned by this that he lets him take
it outside takechi enjoys the sweet
apple that is unlike anything he has
ever eaten a policeman approaches him
and asks him to come to the police
station because he was accused of
shoplifting when the officer tries to
get forceful takeshi easily defends
himself as a result more policemen come
after him haruka sees him running and
films the interaction before uploading
it to her social media meanwhile takeshi
falls unconscious in front of a house
that belongs to a private preschool
teacher named saeki when he opens his
eyes again saeki informs him that he has
been unconscious for two days the police
came looking for him but the teacher
sent them away since stealing an apple
is not a big crime takechi shows his
thankfulness by doing a complete bow he
also introduces himself as samurai
takeshi and pizza saeki remembers him
from history textbooks but assumes it is
only a coincidence takeshi shaves his
beard with a razor for the first time
and is baffled by it similarly many
small things in the new world surprise
him but he still doesn't question if he
is in the same timeline but then on
being asked his birth date takeshi
reveals he was born in the 18th century
this confirms saiki's suspicion and he
tells takeshi what the current date is
both of them are shocked but do not know
what should be done next in the
following scene we see takeshi cleaning
the house to help saiki he is amazed by
the washing machine and its efficiency
it turns out torah is saiki's grandson
and lives in the same house thus takeshi
and torah also have to live together
which torah is not happy about torah and
haruka meet at a restaurant and find out
the video of takeshi has millions of
views haruka likes the samurai which
makes torah hate him even more out of
spite they are also familiar with
tekechi of the 18th century but they do
not believe the person they are with is
the real tachi meanwhile saiki and
takechi buy an apology gift for the
convenience store manager in turn for
the apple he took then they go to a
restaurant where takeshi enjoys
delicious food which is unlike anything
he has ever tasted when asked what he
wants to do in life he says he will
eventually find a way to go back in time
till then saiki requests him to be a
teacher in his preschool the next day he
is introduced to the preschoolers who
are excited that they get to meet a real
samurai as days pass by they teach him
how to use a smartphone take him to the
store teach him indoor fishing invite
him to their basketball game and so on
meanwhile takechi teaches them the
importance of sticking together in times
of need and other lessons he learned
throughout his life let's be honest
these kids have ipads takeshi probably
doesn't have much to bring to the table
he eventually becomes so famous that the
children's mothers start flirting with
him they bring him cupcakes and sweets
trying to impress him but to catch he is
watching his figure and has a wife back
in the 1800s who he is loyal to a
flashback shows us the time he and his
fellow disciples ryoma and kichi were
insulted by a man named toyo he was a
high-ranking samurai filled with pride
and hatred for everyone lower than him
taketchi's people were so mad at him for
insulting their master that they
demanded him to be killed in a fit of
rage takeshi devised a plan to kill him
it was a bad decision that changed his
life forever his people attacked toyo at
night but accidentally killed a higher
member of a respected family because of
this he was imprisoned and scheduled to
be executed back in the present tekechi
finds torah skipping school after lying
to his grandfather he tells the kid to
get his act together but torah in turn
calls him a burden and orders him to go
away he even tries to fight the samurai
but is shut down quickly as takeshi
lectures him he gets a call from his
master and runs to meet him somewhere in
tokyo a journalist overhears two girls
talking about the viral samurai video on
taking a look at it he recognizes
takeshi the man quickly packs his bag
and flies to the city to catch he is in
after conducting some interviews he
locates his address and goes to saeki's
house when takeshi returns from the
market he thinks the journalist is a
thief he is about to attack him when the
man inquires if he remembers the promise
they made in another flashback we see
takechi and his closest friend ryoma
talking before toyo's assassination
ryoma is not fond of the plan and wants
nothing to do with it hence he leaves
the village promising to meet takechi
sometime in the future it turns out
ryoma also time traveled to the future
six years ago and was never able to
return home hence he adapted to the new
life and is living as a journalist in
tokyo he brings takeshi to their old
town of katsura hama which has changed a
lot they see moments of themselves and
are proud that they were able to leave a
mark on people 150 years ago while
walking by the sea rioma reveals how
much he wants to return to his old town
he has given up hope after so many years
but takeshi still thinks going back in
time is possible he sees his disciples
running to him but it turns out they are
only in his imagination after that the
duo goes to a restaurant and talks over
food since ryoma has lived in the future
longer than takechi he has been able to
research how their lives ended in the
1800s he discloses that takeshi
committed the unthinkable because of the
guilt of killing an innocent man and
ryoma was assassinated six years later
in a different town they even go to
their graves and confirm the stories
taketchi is still paranoid about the
future of their town and its people but
ryuma tells him it doesn't matter
anymore they are 150 years in the future
and people now live in peace and harmony
so they shouldn't think about the past
too much when asked about his wife tomi
takeshi finds out she lived for eight
more years and died of natural causes he
doesn't like to talk about her solely
because he misses her very much suddenly
he notices torah being dragged by a
bunch of men he is being bullied for
money by the neighborhood thugs when
torah insists that he doesn't have any
he is beaten and insulted just then
takeshi and ryoma arrive and ask the
leader of the gang to let torah go
initially the gang makes fun of takeshi
for wearing traditional clothing but
become furious when he refuses to back
down there are 15 of them against the
two but takeshi asks ryoma to stay out
of the fight he uses a metal pipe to
fight them and defeats them all in no
time in the end only the leader is left
who runs away screaming in the following
scene ryoma is at the airport returning
to tokyo he has started a new life there
and is content with the way he is living
ryoma wants to catch you to join him but
he prefers staying with saeki and the
children takeshi used to make origami
with his wife frequently when they were
together life was boring before the
internet he teaches the kids to do the
same in her memory after finding out she
lived half of her life in his memory he
has been missing her a lot lately three
kids want to go to the hills to collect
unique characters in a mobile game they
ask to catch you to join them but he
declines because he wants to visit his
wife's grave instead the kids should go
with him maybe they can catch a cubone
when he is not around the kids plan to
go to the hills alone at night later
torah approaches to ketchi and thanks
him for helping last night he offers to
do anything to return the favor the two
then drive to tomi's grave and pray in
front of it torah didn't believe that he
is the real tachi until he saw him fight
yesterday he is still skeptical but he
tries to reason with the fact somewhere
in the hills three of takeshi students
go into the woods to look for characters
in a mobile game they enter a restricted
area confident that they will find a way
back meanwhile takeshi and torah are
together enjoying ice cream torah
finally asks him if he is a real samurai
and claims that he wants to be his
disciple takechi accepts him as one and
asks him to be ready to exert himself
for his country on his way back home
takeshi insists on walking while torah
rides his motorbike when it gets dark a
crowd of people gather outside saiki's
home looking for the lost children their
mothers are worried because the kids
have been gone for more than five hours
as they are about to organize a search
party a police officer arrives looking
for takechi it turns out that the thugs
he beat up yesterday filed a complaint
against him torah tells the officer what
happened but takeshi still has to be
taken to the police station when he
arrives tora goes looking for him and
finds him on his way back home when told
about the missing kids takeshi remembers
they wanted to go to the hill meanwhile
the boys are about to give up until they
recall to catchy's lessons they know if
they stay together and try their best to
survive they will eventually be found
then they think of an idea to leave
clues around the jungle so people who
come to their rescue know where they are
a while later takechi arrives and finds
the clues after following them for a
while he sees the kids and is proud that
they were brave in the time of crisis
they reunite with their mothers who are
beyond thankful to taketchi however the
policeman then comes forward to arrest
him the children try to stop the officer
which causes a distraction giving torah
a chance to drag to catchy outside they
drive away on his motorcycle but are
suddenly hit by a vehicle torah composes
himself and looks around to see that
takeshi is missing after that day the
samurai never returns the family
eventually comes to terms with the fact
that they will never meet him again
torah and haruka go to one of the
ketchi's monuments to pay respect
although they cannot meet him anymore
the couple is glad they got to know him
then one day saeki gets a call from the
owner of a reputed bank he discloses
that someone has left a letter for him
long before he was even born when the
letter was first found it came as a
surprise to the owner but he knew he had
to give it to his true receiver in the
letter takechi has thanked saeki for his
kindness and told them that he is right
where he is supposed to be he has also
drawn a picture of the preschoolers and
mentioned that torah is his last
disciple it is clear that after
disappearing on the day of the accident
he was transported back in time looking
at the letter torah sheds a single tear
then we see a flashback of what happened
after tekechi returned to the past he
writes a letter for his wife and for
saeki the latter saying that it should
only be opened after 150 years his
enemies mock him because he is about to
be executed but he has already found
peace knowing that the world will
eventually turn into a better place good
thing takeshi never looked at twitter he
is additionally happy that he got to
taste chocolate cake but the rivals
think he is bluffing nonsense in the end
he is made to commit the unthinkable so
people remember him as a coward however
to catch he does it happily knowing that
it won't be the case subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching